bien maintenant on va accueillir
quelqu'un que j'adore
jocelyne de michou nom
geneviève de fontenay
est très dur
j'en suis ravi
jean louis murat et lyon ça fait une
belle course que les maintenant oui tu
ne vises end à l'est mouais g20 comme
nord-eclair mois excédant les artistes
maintenant je fasse tout ce que les
artistes émergents fins que les enfants
des enfants les artistes j'étais vidé
muté car j'avais débuté moi aussi je
t'ai vu débuter la première fois quand
on s'est vus
ben vous viviez vous dessus clermont
ferrand et vous disiez quand on vous
parlait de clermont ferrand c'est une
ville qui a aucun charme le seul charme
c'est que c'est chez moi je vais bien
cette façon reste à cause de murat le
coeur ouais vous connaissez avant vous
êtes de murat-le-quaire moi j'ai des
amis aux dernières avancées des amis au
vernet avant on dirait quoi avant de
chanter avant de faire des disques vous
avez été disquaires été barman et quand
on s'était rencontrés m'avait raconté
une histoire je m'en souviens c'est que
vous me disiez que vous travaillez comme
barman à saint tropez
et que yahvé barclays qui vous est lavé
ses chemises avec ça ces tâches de
mousse au chocolat comme ça et après
vous filez d'issac parce que vous aviez
nettoyer ses chemises elles vous mêmes
départ tous dans un resto ont nettoyé au
ga
mais c'est celle d'une nation est ce que
je vais demander à la pire la pire
injure pour vous c'était voilà répandu
s'étaient donnés à l'autre la honte de
soi une phrase de nietzsche derrière et
là vous avez vous avez honte de vous
barclays à ce moment là bah oui avec le
g en train de nettoyer ça a pris ça file
entre
amis l'incroyable murat mois mais
beaucoup surpris parce qu'un mur a eu un
truc formidable c'est qu'au lieu de
tirer sur les ambulances ils tirent sur
les vaches sacrées est ce qui est quand
même beaucoup plus compliqué surtout
beaucoup plus courageux on avait fait un
blind test il y avait brel et vous aviez
répondu je trouve ça dégoûtant fin il ya
des choses qu'on peut pas dire un peu de
retenue quand même
oui brel ouais vraiment c'est toujours
une chance
non c'était sur le sous le coup de
l'émotion de nan mais j'ai jamais ça
jamais été ma tasse de thé renault non
plus remarqué parce que mehdi pour le
réalisme la journal télévisé
barroso j'ai dit ça c'est pas mal c'est
bien la mère de thomas mann on sait que
10 ans après je le répète donc c'est que
c'est bien
mais dix ans après six ans j'ai pas
beaucoup changé en même temps parce que
sur le web city a déclaré par exemple la
chanson française trimballe des
dinosaures omniprésent
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'ils sont bons
comme toujours les présentateurs télé de
façon ils sont indéboulonnables
ça se passe sur ce sont les
fonctionnaires cabrel ou goldman on n'y
échappe pas penser que cabrel ou que le
major je pense qu'on a on ils ont
phagocyté le marché de record en france
ouais dans le présentateur télé ou les
chanteurs dit durant 50 ans
et pas de renouvellement c'est vrai tu
prends les dans les années 60 c'était
déjà les mêmes choses les années 70 au 6
mai 86 90 et 2010 on va se taper encore
johnny et les goldman cabrel et quota de
titres francophones ans à la radio vous
en pensez quoi moi je passe à la radio
avant que les quotas et après j'ai giclé
depuis qu'elle est qu il passe trois
fois plus
hallyday goldmann ils passent plus des
gars comme trump assez passe en radio
je pense pas du tout
ça vous empêche pas de vendre des albums
quand même non non
vous en prenez aux guignols aussi
mais je m'en prends à
sélectionner au milieu j'ai donné 150
interviews part évidemment vous sortez
une dizaine de phrases et vous pouvez
facilement les gens à prendre non mais
ça en prend le guignol ces courageux
attendait si tu veux pas vous aussi vous
ai dit quoi
ce qui m'intéresse si vous attaquez aux
guignols parce que vous les comparez à
l'action française quand même c'est
violent
oui je trouve que c'est que c'est une
une élite arrogante
qui s'est très très bien se moquer des
petites jambes je fais tu m'énerves
joueur de foot vous avez dit les joueurs
de l'équipe de france sont vautrés dans
le monde médiatique comme des pourceaux
suite à la coupe du monde non quand tu
aime le sport ou le wpt à suivre la
coupe du monde d'un seul coup ça on a
affaire en affaires à ulysse à pénélope
je ne sais quoi elle c'est vrai qu'après
quand on les voit vendredi vendre des
conneries je trouvais que ça manquait de
savants kit classe quoi je pense que les
sportifs au numérique légende médias ils
ont une sorte de rôle éducatif un peu et
qui doivent savoir se tenir de ce qu'ils
servent essentiellement d'exemple ils
sont beaucoup plus exemplaire que que
les saints et que les curés que les
intellectuels malherbe couleurs profs on
a faim on peut les mettre devant leurs
responsabilités je vous avais bien aussi
jean louis murat c'est que vous défendez
les gens qui sont attaqués vous attaquez
les guignols en les comparant l'action
française mais vous dites que virenque
par exemple ceux qui lui ont fait ce
qu'ils lui ont fait devraient tomber
sous le coup de la loi sont des ordures
vous dites oui je pense que la façon de
traiter bien que moi je trouve que c'est
en fait moi j'ai été élevé comme ça les
mecs qui traite un contre est un petit
gars comme ça c'est une ordure et
normalement la loi de refaire son boulot
je pense oui dans toile est là pour
défendre les publics c'est que dans le
cyclisme tout le monde se charge
simplement lui aussi bien sûr mais il
n'a pas les mots pour expliquer qu'il se
charge c'est ça vous fait s'il n'a pas
le dise essentiellement ben oui mais
l'angle des attaques survient un accès
cesson sans vocabulaire et je trouve ça
dégueulasse on se moque de lui parce
qu'il sait pas parler tous a dit m moi
je suis dans un milieu où les gens
moi mes grands parents parlent
essentiellement patois et quand il
parlait en français n'était pas très
très habile je trouve pas ça bien de se
moquer des gens qui savent pas
s'exprimer
et vous arrêtez pas la seule
à raconter des trucs
comme ça
oui bien sûr non c'est juste qu'il est
entièrement d'accord j'ai souvent été
d'accord avec lui non vous avez l'air
quand même mieux dans votre peau qu'à
dix ans
plus serein vous aussi
un premier 45 tours des murs à s'appeler
suicidez vous le peuple est mort je vais
pas retrouvé derrière lui les jurés vous
là bas sinon j'ai pas adressé une copie
aujourd'hui vous êtes
vous êtes plutôt fêté par les médias
vous êtes plutôt bien
bien reconnu j'avoue fait un disque à
libération qu'on fait deux pages
savanes ont cessé à ça c'est vicieux
s'est affichée c'est gentil ça non
pourquoi le dire que libération fait
deux pages dans votre bouche c'est
pourquoi au contraire moi
pas du tout
arrête toi jean louis là dessus c'est
super et adulé aujourd'hui n'en parle
pas mais à part la critique parce que
j'ai deux pages dans libération la route
faute oui dans les inrocks et dans des
tas de journaux qui font l'opinion vous
êtes vous disent tout
tout s'explique
on se demandait tous c'est le maire
était dieu me parfume non je bois un
coin
bar vite j'en ai marre de la tristesse
je préfère la sérénité c'est sa force et
pas bouddhisme est influencé par la
philosophie bouddhiste ça moi vous êtes
mire et gymnastique
très très consensuel en plus maintenant
fait des chansons contre le front
national les grossesses et les [ __ ]
serrer les fesses voilà les grossesses
et les [ __ ] mais gré à gré c'est
pourquoi j'ai fait cette chanson
pourrait chanter à vitrolles
il fallait avoir la chanson je n'avais
pas la chanson est d'accord je suis une
chanson
jazz y en a une aussi
tout le monde il est beau c'est jean
marie le pen vous savez qu'on a c'est
l'épée des papes a attendu sa cette
espèce de
on peut toujours dire ça mais autant le
faire ouais
c'est fait c'est fait on peut toujours
un peu de joueurs de mauvais esprit pour
dire que ça va être tendu
bien qu'à des gens qui est de mauvais
esprit et dans un monde où tout le monde
du bon esprit non croyez pas
this is ici non mais c'est vous qui
posez des questions moi j'ai fini
scarlett o'hara
satisfaite et jamais dans gaza
c'est ce que vous avez dit non je sais
pas comment se fait-il c'est vous et
autant frapper
je me suis posé la question parce que
vous avez 2 vous avez quand même une
séduction qui est assez trouble alors
j'ai trouvé scarlett o'hara à ce qui se
fait déjà
c'est excitant vous ayez sorti cette
pratique assez excitant je suis assez
bien on finit bien c'est quand on est
d'accord il s'appelle hardy c'est très
excitant à oui
qu'est-ce qui vous fascine dans
l'univers féminin justement vous qu'être
fasciné par l'univers féminin
et filles qui ont rausis un peu comme ça
mais qui résiste encore leur parle
d'organes
on était là avant moi ça fait deux mois
qu'on a
c'est vrai ils arrivent ils arrivent
des trucs là ce soir
tu respectes ressentir un sentiment nous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu